[Music]
[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about
everything we know about the second
episode of season 8 supportive
trailers teasers promotion photos and
previews
99 of everything i said in the season 8
episode 1 league scenes video came true
and i'm quite certain most of the things
you hear in this video will happen
exactly
so if you don't want to get potentially
spoiled it's time for you to close this
video
let's start with jaime's child new
promotional photo with armed guards
behind him
many wonder how this meeting will end
for jaime having in mind that brain a
kid he tried to kill and dany a woman he
also tried to kill
and kill her father are the ones who
will decide his fate here
it does look bad for jaime as he's done
some serious crimes against both of
stark and house targaryen
we also know that these were faces of
brienne and davos that we got from
promotion photos belong to the scene
brienne is worried for how danny
targaryen and bran stark will react
then he says to jaime when i was a child
my brother viserys would tell me a
bedtime story
about the man who killed their father
about all the things we would do to that
man
doesn't look good for jaime at all right
when she says all the things he will do
to that man jaime looks to his left hand
in shock
so it's understandable that the first
thought you get is jaime being sentenced
or something like that
and it's okay because the teaser was
made to make us think that
however as i said in my preview
breakdown jaime is not looking at danny
passing him the sentence
or anything like that because if he was
he'd look in front of him
not to his left alright the person on
his left is bran stark
jaime is not shocked about his
punishment but rather about what's brain
got to say about his past
as a matter of fact after dany says to
jaime the story of how she and her
brother viserys used to imagine how they
punished the man who killed their father
i believe danny will also say but i was
wrong basically revealing that she knows
why jaime killed her father and it was
not a crime
tyrion told dany why jaime killed her
father in the ninth episode of the sixth
season
tyrion revealed to the dragon queen that
the only reason his brother jaime killed
her father was because the mad king
wanted to burn the city to the ground
along with its population
so daniel already knows the truth behind
jaime's so-called betrayal over her
father
and will definitely not want to punish
him for that even she herself admitted
her father was an evil
man back in season 7 when meeting jon
snow what actually happens here is jaime
being shocked that all the information
from his past bran is throwing at him
bran will most likely provide more
backstory about jaime and the mad king
after dennis says to jaime that she
understands why he did what he did
and it was the right choice jim is like
how do you know all that
bran will also forgive jaime for pushing
him out the window
because he is not bran stark anymore he
is that we are waving
during the trial brian will likely speak
for jaime vouching for his good
intentions as this photo seems to be
hinting
tyrion and brienne will be proud that
jaime has honored his pledge while dany
and sansa will be a bit suspicious about
his intentions upon finding out that
cersei betrayed them
which they will find out from jaime they
will ask him why did he come to manor
film and his beloved sister and lover is
obviously not going to help them
and why should they even trust him
that's when jaime's line from the
official trailer will come out
he will reply with i promise to fight
for the living and i intend to keep that
promise
in other teasers we also hear jaime
saying this goes beyond loyalty
this is about survival after this trial
jaime will be accepted as an ally
and will be given a norton armor tyrion
and jamie will later have a conversation
from the new episode 2 photos we see
tirion and if you look closely you can
also notice the hilt of jaime's valyrian
steel sword widow's veil
now we know what's going on in this
photo of jaimina stark armor from a few
months back
he's having a chat with his brother just
before the dead arrive and the battle
for winterfell begins
the room behind tyrion looks similar to
the room that danny john and their crews
are discussing their battle plans in the
new photos
our planning meeting beside dany and
john will also include various seminaria
all of which are confirmed to be there
by the photos i think there will be many
more characters than we see in photos on
this meeting
including the lanester brothers sensei
bryan stark
juror davos and probably theon greyjoy
as well who should arrive at wienerfell
at this point
this is my favorite of the bunch john
and arya looked to be making plans for
the fans of winner fell with others
if you look closely on the right side of
arya you'd notice sam's hand
this meeting is happening probably when
zhang gives kids they're coming our
enemy doesn't tire doesn't stop doesn't
feel speech
same looks as he feels more concerned
for john than usual
the defenders of nfl are preparing for
the big attack from the night king
this shot from the trailer where arya is
holding her new weapon is also from
episode 2.
arya's weapon is finished and she has a
conversation with genji where she says i
know death
it's got many phases i look forward to
seeing this one
next we know for certain is happening in
episode 2 is a scene in the crypts
between jon and dany
we've actually known for a few months
about the scene and we also know what i
will talk about
as well as how it ends a few months back
it was revealed that episode 2 will see
the return of the crypts of nfl
which was filmed on its long-standing
location at shane's castle
it was also reported there will be a
scene between two leading cast members
in the crypts
and they'll discuss ned stark's death in
this particular scene
so it's basically something similar to
what we already saw in season seven
when since cynaria discussed ned's death
as well as his statue
now we know for cern that it will be
john and dany discussing ned stark
this means that at this point dany
probably knows joshua lineage
and they are discussing why ned had to
lie to jon i believe they will also
discuss their relationship as well
there's also a high possibility that in
episode 2 danny will learn she's
pregnant and she might share the news
with jon
in episode 2 preview we see worried
faces of jura various centerion
as the animals buy them and probably
enter summer's chambers
where is dany going i think it could be
to mr walken after she's been sick
and that's when she finds out she's
pregnant from other season a teasers we
know that jura will soon after enter
those chambers to see dany
and she does seem a bit upset perhaps
she does learn she's pregnant
and she doesn't know how to feel because
father of her child is her nephew
or perhaps maester tells her she cannot
possibly survive another childbirth
many possibilities here but i believe
danny might reveal to john she is
pregnant
anyways the scene is also said to end
when they hear a horn being blown
as you know in the night's watch a horn
is blown to warn of someone approaching
either rangers returning violence at the
gates or white walkers
we are not sure what the horn means in
this scene but there's definitely
someone approaching winterfell
either reinforcements such as edmure
tully with his riverland forces or
wybokers
depends on when this scene takes place
if it takes place towards the end of
episode which i doubt
then it's the arrival of the night king
if it takes place in the beginning or in
the middle of an episode which i
personally think it does
then it's the reinforcements that are
coming in the very beginning of episode
2 tormund berrican ed will arrive at man
that survived fall of the wall
john asks him how long do we have
tormund replies with before the sun
comes up tomorrow
they know the night king and his army
will be upon them soon and they are
preparing their stand at winterfell
many shots of the preparations for the
war although episode 1 was an episode of
reunions episode 2 still holds some
reunions
here we can silly in a moment decked out
in an armor in preparation for the
incoming by boker attack on minefall
behind her we see soldiers from bear
island what happens in this scene is
most likely a reunion between lien and
george moment
we know how harsh lady mormont is and we
know that jarrah brought great shame
upon his house in the past
so i'm not sure how will the syrian play
out jura was stripped of his lordship
upon being caught selling poachers into
slavery which he did to afford finding
his wife's expensive tastes
this reunion is definitely going to be
interesting we'll also see bran stark
beside the weirwood tree
and here he is probably having visions
of past present and future events
we know an actor who's playing gregor
targaryen was back for filming scenes in
season 8.
so we know for a fact bran will see more
visions involving rhaegar
although i cannot guarantee it will be
in this vision and in this episode
after the preparations for the battle
are done and when all there's left is
for the night king and his army of the
dead to attack
the living will have a few moments of
peace and quiet to sit around
fire eat and perhaps say farewell as
many will not survive the battle for
winterfell
sansa and john will have a conversation
at dinner and they will probably talk
about how they are still family
no matter he is not her actual sibling
but rather a cousin
fun fact this dinner will be prepared by
davos seaworth
the next thing we know is taking place
in episode 2 is the meeting between the
lady of winterfell and the dragon queen
in the library at winterfell
she's sporting a new coat and looks
thoughtful then he says to her you never
should have trusted cersei
and sansa replies with you never should
have either since implies to dany
trusting cersei and her word she sent
her army snort was not smart
however the good news is that the
rivalry between these two will probably
stop in episode 2
as there's a promotional photo from this
same scene in which we can see dany
smiling
what episode 2 basically is is preparing
for battle for winterfell against the
night king
and the dead will arrive at the very end
of the episode while the entire third
episode will be about an actual battle
for winterfell
where many will die better fell is
preparing for the upcoming war with
soldiers forming up and
blacksmiths forging journalists weapons
and defenses in full
not only will everyone build dragonless
weapons but all the defenses will be
made out of journalists as well
including the fences on the walls this
will come handy when the dead start
climbing the walls
arya trains with bow and arrow to
possibly be able to kill the white
walkers from afar
we know of killing white vocals is of a
huge importance in winning this war
because if you kill one white walker
otherwise he is raised from death
also fall with him this is the reason
why walkers probably will not fight on
the front lines
but arya might use their second weapon
of choice to deal with that problem
arrows will have dragonglass points
juror gets hard's bane
sam's valyrian steal sword this already
predicted would happen since sam is not
a great fighter
and probably will not be on the first
line so his good friend jorah would
probably be better to use it
then we have a few shots you've already
seen in the official trailer
jar commands dennis forces outside
winterfell
they will not be the only forces who
will face the night king outside
there are also the unsullied and the
knights of the vale here we have jon on
the left
same on the right and probably theon
greyjoy in the middle
remember that upon rescuing yara theon
was granted permission by his queen to
go for winterfell
and help the stars defend it so i think
he's arrived and this is him
davos centerian lannister will be on the
walls of nfl as well
as they will wait for the night king to
attack davos centerion will be
commanding archers
episode 2 will end exactly how the
official trailer ends with the night
king's arrival at the doorstep of
winterfell with the living armies ready
and lined up for the battle
okay guys that will be everything we
know about the season 8 episode 2
support with all the trailers teasers
previews and a few spoilers
how do you like the second episode of
the final season and what do you think
will also take place
please make sure to let me know in the
comment section down below and as always
i hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our channel and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace